[Music]
it must
babe yeah can you smell this I'm gonna
first do it fries oh I probably shut it
okay can I have a PHY sure we make
something healthy for dinner tonight
yeah sure and tomorrow we'll just go to
outer space and have like banana with
some aliens
did you just check him out look oh
please you know you're the only thing I
want to spread all over me right dad
hotter gonna follow your mama mama you
know you know we're not talking right
now is it just me or is it kind of cute
oh thank you
maybe we should keep it as a pet i J I
just needed Burma breed also maybe
tomorrow morning you know oh well I
don't mind if you tune a little it's
just the sound of love well okay but no
BUTT STUFF I'll order you a shower I was
I was gonna shower and why are you on
the couch
oh good shower together
[Music]
stop silly the blanket I'm not stealing
it I'm defending against when you steal
it later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it must be it must be love
good to see you
can see
for me